do villains have defining moments
i think that they certainly can uh
sometimes we get villains who are
very cardboard cut out
just
you know gleefully
wreaking havoc uh for for the heck of it
but
i think of a
of a classic
uh film spider-man 2
and
there doc ock has a defining moment he
is an evil for the sake of evil
he is a man who is wounded through the
death of his wife
that's the moment that defines him
and
in
spider-man 2
written by the same writer who wrote
ordinary people
we get
a villain who actually
has an arc
and who transforms and in the end
is able to
take a step back
from
[Music]
the evil and
to
actually sacrifice himself
uh
to join with spider-man
and
uh to save the city
so
yes i and i think that spider-man 2
plays a really important role in the
history of
superhero action films
we look back and
uh we may not recognize that because
we're used to superhero action films
that have rich character development
but spider-man 2 really
took that up a huge step
by
um
in part
looking deeply in to the character of
their villain and by providing
the
uh the depth and complexity and
dimension
that
defining moments
afforded that character
and when we do see these defining
moments for these villains
is it to to have the audience turn
to to have some empathy toward
that antagonist or is it just to further
understand sort of the arc of the story
i think the effect is that we actually
do have some empathy
uh for that villain
and and it's not to say that we like the
villain or we agree with the evil the
villain does
but it's to say that we recognize the
villain's humanity
and we say oh
you are
at least a little bit like me we are the
same species
and there are a lot of different ways to
approach villains we can approach
villains as other
just completely different from me and
outside of me
but
you think about
pinocchio so if we go way back to
a very disturbing children's animated
film
a scene where pinocchio is at the pool
hall
and
he and the other boys are
drinking and smoking cigars and playing
pool and being transformed into donkeys
that's a vision of evil
that
says
oh
there is no difference
between us and them
we are them
and that
is
a cautionary tale but it also does lead
to a kind of empathy where we can
recognize
oh that villain is really broken
and what they're doing may be
horrible and actually we may call it
evil
but they are also one of us
and
uh
for my storytelling money
that's
uh that's closer to what i
resonate with as like yeah i think
that's how it is
how are the decisions of the villain
different from the hero
in many ways the hero and villains
decisions are the same they're driven by
the way they see the world and what they
want
when i
am writing
[Music]
an antagonist and i will often think in
terms of antagonist as opposed to
villain
because villain
[Music]
is more condemning than i think i'm i'm
ready to be with most of my characters
um joseph mengele certainly was a
villain and
did
pure evil
and he was a human
which is what
made him so interesting to me as a
character
what allowed us to write joseph mengele
in a way that
i think was so disturbing
and
ended up getting the actor
best actor nomination for the european
film award
was that
um we approached him as a character who
thought he was the hero
and i think that
everyone sees themselves as the hero of
their story
they do what they do for the reasons
they do them
and even when they do something that
they would recognize is like okay that
was bad
but you have to understand i had a
really good
justification why i had to do that
it's part of the genius of michael
corleone's character
we understand with every choice he makes
why he makes it and we cringe because
sometimes he's killing family members
but we always recognize
the reasons that he does it
and it creates this cognitive dissonance
for us because we're saying oh no that's
like don't you shouldn't do that
and at the same time i totally
understand why you just did that
i think that gives us really fascinating
antagonists and villains
if
we do
we do the same character development for
them
that we do for any other character
i don't think that means we have to have
really fuzzy moral judgment i think we
can still
recognize evil as evil
and recognize the humanity of the people
who are doing the evil at the same time
it's um
it's a more nuanced approach i think
it's
more interesting and i think again i
think it
it rings true to me for how people
actually are i haven't like i don't
think i've ever met
a villain
at vaughn's you know i i i've
i've met people doing dumb things and
being irresponsible and
uncaring
but
they think they're right
and
so
i i try to approach all my characters
with love
even the ones that are
wicked
how do writers get audiences to care
about the villains
i think that
on the one hand
you could get away with the audience not
caring about the villains even
gleefully rooting
for the destruction of the villain
but
the example of
2 shows us that there is
emotional
gold to be mined
in providing
a glimpse into the humanity
of
a villain
so the in the same way
that we would
reveal a character
say a heroic character to the audience
so that they can understand where that
character's coming from
we can use those same tools
to reveal
who this villain is and why this villain
is how
what journey this character has been on
to arrive at their villainy
the
i think the emotional experience then
becomes really complex
because now
[Music]
i am
i recognize that character
has to be stopped
uh i'm thinking of the camp commandant
in schindler's list
where we really do get
some insights into this character into
his vulnerability into
there's
there's a moment where
he toys with showing mercy
to people
and
then he
pulls back from that it's like that's
not me i'm not i'm not going to be that
guy who is merciful
but the fact that he had that moment
where he could have been merciful
colors the way we feel about him when
he's executed at the end of the film
it makes it more complicated in a way
that i think enriches
the experience
never confuses us
about the evil that he's perpetrated
the film never has any confusion about
that the evil is evil
but it does show us the complexity of
the person perpetrating the evil which
does i think
make for a more interesting
storytelling experience